>>> AND FANS ARE NOT PUCK.
PARAYKO, LEHKONEN, LANDESKOG AND
MACKINNON HUSTLING TO IT.
NEAR WORDS WITPASS TO NICHUSHKI
ONE-TIMER.
DANGEROUS PASS, AND IT GOT >> B
SETTLED BY THOMAS.LLOWS IT UP A
EL BOEF OF THE GOAY OF
TOROPCHENKO.N IT.
SHOT, SAVE MADE.
REBOUND, THEY SCORED!
J.T. COMPHER HAS TIE DIDN'T HAP
>> Shane: ABSOLUTELY.
GREAT PLAY BY MANSON.
THS BACK.
SCHENN, KYROU, SCORES! ABLE TO
THIS IN AND PUT PRESSURE ON.
BUT JOHNSON LOST THE HANDLE AND
HERE IS THE PASS.
IN THE SLOT.
MAKAR ON THE GOAL LI THE EXCHAN.
TO THE FRONT.
CHANGED DIRECTIONS AND KUEMPER
MADE DEFENSIVELY.
AS -- GOT UP O
CAME BACK OUT THROUGH THE LEGS
OF KUEMPER AND STAYEM THOMAS.
DOWN TO THE ICE WENT HELM.
>> Brendan: IN CASE YOU AR
PUCK STUCK IY D TO D AND
EXCELLENT PASS BY MAKAR TO FIND.
AND HE -E PUCK.
TOOK HIM OUT.
BURAKOVSKY BACK ON HIS FEET WITH
RANTANEN.
PLAY CONTINUES.
FOR
MAKAR.
MAKAR AND MACKINNON.RAM, CARRIE
IN.
COMPHER.
SHOT, SHD SHOT.
NOT ONE THAT NORMA A SHOT BY DA.
THAT LINE, THE WORK THEY PUT.